foul oder was geht ab hier ist oder max
und wir spielen heute einen kleinen
changing guetta und die ein bisschen
aggression bei mir verursacht das ist
gerade mein vierter irgendwas aufnahmen
versucht ich probiere nämlich in f5 eine
runde zu gewinnen bzw zu spielen ich
werde es glaube ich einfach die jetzige
aufnahme verwerten egal wie sie ist wahr
ich finde man muss auch nicht jeder
change die man hochlädt bestehen
verdammte kacke
ja ich bin ich bin vielleicht ein
bisschen beruf gerade es ist irgendwie
echt schwierig nehmen sie die ganze zeit
hayes oder ist so schwer ist es doch gar
nicht mehr fünf so man rennt ja
eigentlich immer bei minecraft irgendwie
f5 und aber ich finde es doch ein
bisschen schwierig muss ich sagen weil
es irgendwie total strecke ist diese
doofen abstände immer einzelne
einzuhalten
und vor allem kann man längst nicht so
schnell unterwegs sein wie wenn man es
einfach ist wenn man normal spielt weil
man es einfach gewohnt ist nun einfach
so richtig waschen karten stunden
möglich also einfach so ganz schnell
durchlaufen
hier musst du immer gucken ok passen die
abstände und so oder sterbe ich einfach
weil ich nicht sehe dass ich nicht auf
den block sondern gegen den block
springe ja das sind die schwierigkeiten
dieser challenge aber ich glaube wir
können es schaffen wenn wir fest daran
glauben rede ich irgendwie so ein
bisschen anime live video stil der
kommission
da kann ich nicht versprechen irgendwas
machen
ja
nein kann ich nicht ich bin glücklich
ich bin 325 platz 2 regina ziegler
schnitzel flockt warum fragst du nicht
und spielst götter und wo du einfach
andere wird nur ab fax dadurch dass du
so viele punkte kriegst vielen dank
tschüss herr übelste abfall dieser typ
hätte es einfach richtig stark in ruhe
lassen wir einfach wo ich will einfach
nur diese pack 1 kriegen und einfach mal
was schaffen in dieser blöden challenge
diese leute die einem nichts can do
verfluchter drecksack ich bin so was zu
blöd um mich zu rechnen also kein scheiß
ich lasse jetzt meinen rache streifen
feldzug fertig und probiere einfach
weiter calls zu kriegen deshalb hieß der
sinn von wörtern ist offen haben leute
nach es will nicht klappen
die challenger wie echt verrückt so
53111 jason toohey wollte ich mal gesagt
hat das ist das ist so ganz übel finde
ich so wenn man einer anderen block
hinter sich hat und dann die entfernung
noch behinderte abschätzen kann als ganz
normaler kann
komm schon 26 hat platz eins an abstand
der wahl noch einmal über mich drüber
nein jetzt bin ich nicht mehr auf der
höhe von den beiden blöcken komplett
bevor der andere finnische abstand hat
genau ich glaube jetzt will ich einfach
dieser schnitzel blog typ schon wieder
dampf macht nicht so was von fertig
leute ich habe gesagt ich nehme diese
runde ich werde jetzt echt alles geben
das sich noch irgendwie gewinnen kann
indem ich irgendwie klug einkaufen oder
so und mich dann hoch feitel mehr oder
weniger gehen nochmal ganz cool aber ich
kann wirklich nichts versprechen
ich bin schon eigentlich zufrieden so
die letzten runden weichen noch
schlechter weil ich auch ein bisschen
eingespielt mit mittlerweile der
challenge aber ich stehe einfach so
häufig so dumm weil ich dachte das wird
mir so zwei herzen oder was zocken und
es waren einfach 4
jetzt habe ich die runde sowieso durch
und jetzt kommt die letzte die letzte
runde
ich bin so unteres mittelfeld was punkte
angeht wirklich behaupten
auf jeden fall hier wieder rein und
glück versuchen diesen panda typen muss
ich auf jeden fall ausschalten wer auch
immer das ist der mich am anfang so
freundlich genervt hat
ich finde die rache ist legitim in get
down also kann man schon machen wenn
april
dafür ist das glaube ich voll cool also
da diese jetzt bin ich voll ausgegangen
gerissen erst sprachlos war
dafür kann man die f15 mega gut nutzen
für diese sprühen
wo einfach eine irgendwie also über
einen block vier blöcke drüber nation
ein anderer normaler blog ist da kann
man das mega gut benutzen
aber ja ich stehe hier wie so ein
verrückter auf dem bildschirm und wie
müssen mich voll konzentrieren also
wirklich hat echt kein glück bisher
dieser challenge bzw mit der aufnahme
session besser gesagt ich möchte nur
noch ein paar 11 177 abstand hat der
erste platz das sollte ich sein so roth
kampf 154 überhaupt nicht auf dem auf
dem pfad den ich gewählt habe
gibt es verschiedene schichten ist hätte
doch geklappt was mache ich denn falsch
wirklich ich sehe dass und irgendwie
okay du schaffst den sprung und dann
wegen diesem verfluchten f5 zeug klappt
es einfach nicht also wirklich diese
changes geiseln nicht wirklich das ist
wirklich schlimm für uns normal gehen
kann ich auch nicht mitnehmen 14 abstand
hat er
der erstplatzierte sechs perfekten adria
mitgenommen leute ich stehe jetzt okay
wer gibt mir viel zeit zu zählen so
leute jetzt geht's in den shop ich habe
achten dass 32 points und ich habe
wirklich alles gegeben gerade dass ich
dann auch irgendwie ein paar coins komme
ich werde jetzt einfach auf einen guten
boden gehen und ich hoffe dass die zeit
erlaubt war ich habe auch gerade eben
bei einer runde davor wollte auf dem
guten bogen gehen und habe einfach ich
glaube ja 50 sekunden der zeit damit
zugebracht darauf zu warten dass ich mal
infiniti und flame kriege also wirklich
ich konnte nichts machen und ca jetzt
geht es einigermaßen so war ich möchte
nämlich
darauf hoffen dass irgendwie diese
wasserkarte kriegen und damit 6
schneider führt action diesmal gut
irgendwie was zu reißen
glaub mir noch den enterhaken weil dann
werde ich wahrscheinlich relativ gut
kombinieren können so zwischen
enterhaken und bogen dass ich halt das
erste mal irgendwie ein bisschen rüstung
kriege also ihr wisst schon so von wegen
mit enterhaken den typen vorbeiziehen
dann bogen schon brennt kann ich rennen
wichtig ist auf jeden fall dass wir
irgendwas mit wasser machen weil das 33
ihr wisst ihr seht es ist ziemlich op
vor allem am anfang
bevor ich geld habe später dachte ich
diese dieses entscheidend so gar nicht
auf dem schirm weil es halt schon hart
eigentlich und da hat mir immer so ok ok
das ist keine karte mit wirklich viel
wasser als ob da macht einfach genau das
gleiche
er macht exakt die gleiche challenge was
ich fress ich spreche schon nur noch in
ist da noch der panda typen meint mein
hass gegner
und er geht ins wasser
jetzt hat er zum guten bogen aufgehoben
ich weiß es nicht mehr
er hat auf jeden fall auch einen guten
bogen leute leute was soll das denn hier
werden alte komm schon
also das macht die gerade ein bisschen
verrückt ist nicht funktionieren will o
komm schon
also gestern mit wenig konz macht echt
nicht so viel spaß wie geht man mit
vielen kreuzen sagte mal ein weiser mann
dieser weise mann war ich
gott lass mich mit dem wurf okay okay
ich sollte rentnerin ist frei
ich habe leider nicht vergessen ich am
ford ein wasser vorteile
das war's